what is the aim of Iman Channel what is
the aim of most demanding them doing
this event a lot upon life yeah is it
light upon light or Darkness upon
Darkness
somebody prays once Allah in the Haram
it's as if they have prayed 100
000 salahs they start praying five times
a day for 54 years we have a brother
here who we are teaching how to pray
Salah and in fact many people learn from
this match and come to the Haram and if
you donate it for one mat and somebody
played two days Salah here it's
equivalent to one million salahs anyway
this is not including their daily
prayers throughout their life and them
teaching their children click the button
or the link and be a part of this
amazing project
foreign
[Music]
events where 15 000 people come break
you've started to give up um have you
started to give up break the force to
give up uh do tarawi together
and this year was the same and I was
invited specifically this year to do a
speaker squana style Tao stool and I was
alhamdulillah and I'm going to be
talking about
um you know myself personally about
these events what I think about them but
in general there's been a videos going
around Tech talk about people
complaining I think there was a since
I've done it live I don't know I don't
really see it but she's done it live
complaining about you know the benefits
of this or the harms or I remember I
think it was very like you know
criticizing that there's free mixing
intermingling and all that kind of stuff
Handler so I'm going to touch up on this
because it's very very important now I
will bring my channel closely so there
could be a conflict of interest but I
feel Allah also because Allah says in
the Quran speak the truth even if it's
against yourself or your kin now I have
to be just I mean if this was something
that I disagree with in my channel I'll
privately speak to them and give them
the CEO I would leave people for doing
the video but I'm not going to do that
why not because I want anything from
them
if I am saying this because I work with
them okay no anyone that knows me knows
me what kind of person I am I don't care
who offers what to me or what benefits I
have from them I will speak the truth I
don't care if they stop working me I
don't care yeah Allah provides my risk
not to you so I want to be very open
with you because I was there today and
I'm going to tell you how it was okay
now first thing first brother and
sisters is that when I went there I had
my doubles too I was there and many
people came people came so bad about
this if Allah knows everything and we
have a will how does that work we have
sisters coming about hijab how can I
start you know wearing hijab we had
brothers and sisters come in that saying
that they're sinful Etc around
relationships how can I make Halal um
there was people who were asking
questions there were two non-muslims
come came on the verge of accepted Islam
um you name it so many different
questions a sister came about divorce
whatever it may be you know so much
stuff so much emotions one of them was
crying subhanallah so alhamdulillah it
was very very beneficial alhamdulillah
useful and the point is the following
guys yeah now with this kind of stuff
you need to understand something if we
look at it from a perspective for
example I've been practicing for about
10 years okay I can say that you know
I'll do the basics handle it yeah now if
I go to these events and I look at it
from my perspective where I am now yeah
okay and if you guys are watching this
and you are Pious or whatever it may be
and you are looking at from there the
question I would ask you is why are you
even going there I'll now ask a very
simple question if you know for example
there might be something that you might
dislike to your taste yeah for example
why are you going there you should be in
a better place if you believe that they
went up to notch or scratch whatever
they're doing why are you even there you
should be in your house I mean
especially a sister I would say why are
you even there if you're going to
criticize it why are you even there the
question can be asked you know we can go
down this rabbit hole and be like Hold
on Sister why are you even going there
with that why are you even going there
without your husband even if your
husband was there why are you guys even
there for if we're gonna make it seem as
if this was an intermingling free mixing
event where most demand because
promoting all this kind of stuff number
one I'm gonna say the following test
okay we need to get over our high horse
because Allah says in the Quran that
indeed he found Julius and he guided Jew
yes okay now brothers and sisters you
need to understand get off this piety
piety attack it's a piety attack okay in
a nutshell I went on Tick Tock and I was
thinking okay what's going on I went
through a lot of videos okay I saw
sisters there okay like on a tick tock I
was just going and I was seeing what
kind of people have come there okay and
I was just looking like going through
and I was saying okay what kind of
sisters are these individuals I would
press on the account and I read that
some of them I would like obviously
press and I'll realize that they don't
even wear hijab so I would just go back
to the videos and I realized there were
people there who were not even
practicing who were not even wearing the
hijab literally one of the sister who
was wearing the hijab in the event I saw
it I was thinking what's she saying
about it how she found it she found it
very pleasant the food the atmosphere
and I went to an account and I zoomed
back out because I realized that the
sister doesn't forget when hijab she
dressed very inappropriately so I had to
fly out of account I thought spent a lot
but it made me realize something that
this sister was not even forget when
hijab she was dressed inappropriate
account yeah may Allah guide on us okay
and I thought to myself subhanallah if
as a person who is practicing goes to
that event I can criticize a lot of
stuff I'm telling you I could have
number one was there free mixing yes yes
did I see people kind of intermingling
can you say yes there was I'll be honest
with I saw this stuff happening yeah was
it like everybody's doing it nonsense
yeah now let me tell you that somebody
who has a good who thinks from it from a
perspective of you know what what are
what is the aim of Iman Channel what is
the aim of most demanding them doing
this event life upon life yeah is it
light upon light or Darkness upon
Darkness I Believe It's light upon light
why because the prophet Muhammad peace
before him said the following and I'm
going to read it for you guys okay he is
said the most beloved places on Earth
Allah is the massage it and the most
despite place on Earth are to Allah are
the markets the marketplaces now just
bear this in mind if we lived under an
Islamic country Islamic State yeah would
there be markets yes there will be
markets is the profanity forbidden
markets because you want to say clearly
it's Haram for you to go to the markets
no he's not he's saying that there are
evil there now if they're evil there is
there also good there yes there are
people who are doing trade the people
who are doing work there are people who
are going there genuinely to do shopping
amongst them are there people who want
to go to intermingle free mix yes now
this image I don't have a responsibility
on every single individual and put CCTV
camera on that no because the dean says
you as a person are accountable Iman
channel did this amazing thing and I
believe it's amazing why because people
from all different backgrounds sisters
who don't wear the hijab promises were
doing drugs smoking weed doing this I
spoke to so many people so many people
and I thought this event is a full event
of Sinners including me we're all
Sinners but we are trying to better
ourselves and when I spoke to them and I
understood this now was there free
mixing happening yes there was there was
happening but how is that organizer's
fault if you've got a marketplace where
people are going to going to shop Etc
and people are talking to each other
whatever how could you wake up the
Sharia please come and do it like the
Hadith says the Hadith forbade the
marketplace says no it said there are
places where it's disliked Allah because
of this but the taraweehamdulillah was
amazing 15 000 people Muslims were not
practicing connecting to the Lord they
had 19 shahadas yes 19 shahadas sisters
praying Tara in the 27th night Brothers
praying tarawi they could have been
anywhere else they could be in God knows
in the clubs doing drugs doing this not
even fasting the fact that they come
into the Islamic event they had to
observe the hijab those who were not
even wear the hijab they were observing
hijab those who insult and swear use
foul language brothers or whatever it
may be they had to keep their tongue you
know so there were so many benefits out
of it so to go and only take as if all
the evil this is nonsense while lying
you've got is it can be a form of
Kimberly of arrogance why would you look
at this event and see nothing but evil
subhanallah like ebentamia says and
always use this some people are like a
fly all you want you went to the event
the Freemason others is that the only
thing you saw you saw nothing good you
didn't see the tarawi being prayed
sisters were not wearing the hijabi
brothers were involved in drugs and
whatever it may be praying there
breaking a star together remembering
Allah having Nasir praying Salah
together nothing none of that it was
just evil get the hell out of here
please with all due respect get the hell
out of here trying to make this event
you know it's dark and stuff on Darkness
one light was a light upon light it was
were there some darknesses in the sense
of people sinning of course there was
but it is unjust for us to not move and
be like yeah let's get the hell out of
here man get the hell out of here just
imagine this imagine you are a
non-practicing young girl or a young boy
would that place be somewhere good or
bad for you it would be the most perfect
place for you that is the problem that
we have we do not okay from a
perspective of a young girl who's
dressing inappropriately or a brother
who's also dressing inappropriately or
doing God knows what committing what
coming to an event where you'll realize
that it's a Muslim event you have to
conduct yourself in a certain way you're
coming there and you're seeing it and on
top of that you're coming and praying
tarawi maybe they did not pray at all in
that Ramadan pray in tarawi breaking
iftar seeing the Brotherhood giving
Nasir talking hearing a reminder 19
shahadas Subhan Allah but if you want to
get on your high horse animal Pious and
you know where I'm in a cup and I wear
my fob like me subhanallah and I go and
go look at these people they don't feel
like he's arrogant while Allah he is
arrogance if you came to that event or
look from a certain perspective and said
oh this is how it shouldn't be wallahi
arrogance do not forget Allah guided you
my dear sister is whatever you're
wearing and my brother who's got a long
beard under his left arm and must walk
in his big teeth you don't ever forget
that day and that point where you used
to commit Xena you used to drink alcohol
you used to do drugs you used to do the
most filthy for acts and there was one
reminder in a Masjid or one video here
or one this year there that slowly got
you to guidance that you are now
practicing and now you're in your high
horse mashallah looking at people and
these people don't fear Allah
who cares about Allah's messenger we're
going to do this alhamdulillah I know
and I can vouch for these individuals I
can vouch for them I know I'm an Iman
Channel and the head of image I'm not
going to mention my name is a brother
who fears Allah wants the best for the
ummah and always gives me always always
when I do a video it might be something
that's not for he was a message he made
me take down two videos he messaged me
who do you think I am the great one
million subscribers please sir kiss my
hand I say no I hear you right I see
where you're coming I took the video
down he wants goodness for the ummah so
I tell everybody to Fearless
if I'm seeing the statements about him
because I want something from I don't
want nothing from him I do not see it
I'm seeing what I see these brothers
want good for the um they're making
these events so we can come together
that's all I'm going to say brothers and
sisters inshallah may Allah protect and
preserve us and make us among those who
have who help others and not be
judgmental he does that he doesn't look
at him look at him Allah will test you
in such a way that brother assists on
this events that you look at wallahi
Allah
to that sister dress inappropriately
that you have a go at or look at you
will be worse than them and if you can
do it come you do an event let's see how
well you can do it dividing markets
let's see how easy it is that you're
gonna have brothers in one side let's
see how easy it is you know the one who
doesn't know how to do it he talks a lot
and the one that knows how to do it does
it so email the forgive all of her
shortcomings inshallah and may Allah
bless Iman channel that they do more
events like this that can benefit all
the ummah at large and of course there's
going to be things that happen that are
not perfect may Allah forgive us